ja meine Damen und Herren kaum könnten
die ersten zaghaften Sonnenstrahlen vom
Ende des Winters rumpen-oliver
ferngesteuerte Geisteskranke in die
Eisdiele laut Statistik verspachtelt
jeder Deutsche im Jahr ein 110 Kugeln
Eis im Jahr 110 Kugeln das schaffe an
eurem Vormittag wirklich wirklich
italienische Eisdiele wo Frau Bergmann
in einem gnadenlosen Selbstversuch für
uns die trennsorten des Jahres 2016
probiert hallo und herzlich willkommen
in der echte italienischen Eisdiele
Gelateria Paradiso die Angelo
zu sprechen ihre Jahrzehnte ist das so
Sex
aber erstens habe ich überhaupt keinen
Akzent und zweitens zaubern sie mir
nicht die Jacke voll
die ganze Zeit ihre Augen sind wie eine
römische Gebirg sie bei Sonnenuntergang
in die Toskana meine Augen sind doch
braun aber bei uns in Italien alles
sehen Sie braune jetzt hat Schluss mit
diesem Süßholz geraspel Frau Bergmann
sie werden hier nicht fürs flirten
bezahlt
ja ihre Chefin ist da nur reitversuchtig
weil andere Mann sie will haben als Muse
ja das stimmt weil wenn hier jemand muss
aus der Frau Bergmann macht dann bin ich
wieso stronzo selber ausgesucht
aber heute muss sie machen die Gelati
Liebe mit die Waffel und darum habe ich
etwas ganz Besonderes
wie auch schon Friedrich also Herr grün
war jetzt zeigen sie mal nicht so
ignorant ein bisschen Exotik hat noch
keinen geschadet
das schmeckt ja wie Arsch und Friedrich
schmeckte wie die Arsch von die
friedlich aber ich noch ganz besondere
schau mal her hier ist noch wunderbare
Knoblauch Deal und hier ist Banane
Gorgonzola mit die ziemlichste Himmel
von die ganze Welt
Frau Bergmann Brause Kübelchen
seniorine Bergemann wenn du musste
übergeben kann ich brauche für neue
Sorte Obatzda
ich brauche gleich den ganzen Eimer
Frau Bergmann darf ich Sie an dieser
Stelle zu ihrem unglaublichen Talent
beglückwünschen überall auf der Welt
Leute mit Dachschaden aufzutreiben das
ist doch vor Eis was der Trottel da
zusammenpanscht Eis schmeckt nach
Vanille nach Erdbeer oder Schokolade
alles andere ist kein Eis sondern ein
Scheißdreck
ja red nur du Blätter her du Granaten
bis zum Anschlag ein Betrüger ich hab's
gewusst in dem Moment mit dem stimmt
irgendwas nicht
cool
sie sind gar kein echte italienischer
Italiener
zu machen
aber wir bleiben hier steht oder drauf
nein
das Lokal
Salon
Fernseh
kriegst du nämlich ein wunderbares
zwiebelrotan
nein
helfen sie mir toll ich bin doch nicht
bescheuert und liege mit der Mafia an
ja und da fährst jetzt ja hier aber
vorher kriegst eine wunderschöne
italienische Betonschuhe ab mit dir
irgendwie komme ich aus dieser Nummer
raus ja und dann stehen diese ganze
Partner von vorne
und hinten
[Applaus]